[Music]
and power trip nose tripping submitted
by tea and crumpets I think I've ever
had tea and crumpets late I've had tea
but I don't know what a crumpet is it's
a basic cracker yeah is it cracker is it
like a good instrument I thought I was
like a muffin it's a little crumb / it's
a little crumb poor girl with the
trumpet yeah a professor is accused of
stealing a student's invention to make
millions pharmacy professor oh I could
totally see that happening ya know cuz I
was still picturing I was like most
students are really dumb so they're not
gonna invent [ __ ] in college I don't
think so but then when you said pharmacy
professor no those students are kind of
smart and I could see them [ __ ] look
this is how hard we pull [ __ ] out of her
ass most of the people who work at
universities do and breakthroughs are
students [ __ ] yeah that's just he
comes from one of those schools he
graduated from that like the people were
cured cancer I dog [ __ ] yeah but like
90% of them are just like petri dish
monitors 90% of them are just like rat
strokers or a petri dish rat strokers
[ __ ] you that's great dirty cousin I
heard him say that can I can see his
hand movement thank you meant like
jerking like your towel reminds me I'm
doing all these my dumb ass thought it
was children playing with construction
paper and they took that in [ __ ] made
millions out of their Oh like little
students yeah
Tammy we gotta invent that [ __ ] where we
can go into people's heads man I want to
see what the [ __ ] everyone thinks no cuz
once they do that the world will end
I only one only one no cuz what they'll
do is they'll be like you had racist
thoughts on Miss dead time and you're
going to shave
no I said me only one being inventor
what else what if she spots a million
times it does not me part all the time
definitely not Steve green not Steve
green that's who this next place at the
University of Missouri Kansas City and
they're alleging the University filed a
lawsuit I've been there before
yay it's nice just for you Joe it's
really nice I'm sure that that helps all
them too yep university is soon I bet
you there's students that are watching
JK news right now and they're like so
thankful that I gave them recognition
and baby but you didn't give him she
gave him the recognition you said I went
there no no but they're like Oh Joe
thinks it's cool oh hell yeah we're to
the right school I want to give a shout
out to all Jennifer's watching this
Jennifer or shout it all the Jennifers
are now saying thank you for recognizing
Steve green thank you so much
you guys don't understand people anyway
so this doctor yeah yeah professor sigh
so he apparently stole this
groundbreaking drug formulation from a
student and he sold it for 1.5 million
dollars but he stands to gain as much as
10 million more in what the university
is suing this professor so the
university says that any student that
comes out with any sort of invention is
property of the university they want the
money Ben I fell well the student would
get a portion of it like a thousand
dollars no so it's one third of profits
and the remaining two-thirds of the
school so I actually have some insight
on this bigger than nothing my
brother-in-law is a professor at UC as
Dee and he runs his own lab they talk
about this [ __ ] and he he'd the yeah he
deals with all this [ __ ] cuz he's in
charge of lab so when they have a if
they have a discovery breakthrough
whatever the [ __ ] then yeah it goes down
the list of like him and then the
students involved and then like it gets
all broken out like when we do a brand
deal it's like you gotta kick it to this
person so he would have had a cut he was
just being greedy yeah I want it all
well I don't know so the professor would
Russert the person running the lab gets
a
yeah because the professor's like the
captain yeah and then they have to like
I mean I get from the university
standpoint cuz they're providing the
like a facility facility and the
materials and the stuff to do it like I
get it yeah but also [ __ ] this guy cuz
like yeah so they're saying here and
they're also named in the lawsuit is his
wife because she also worked in the lab
and there's also two pharmaceutical
companies that use the invention that
are named in the lawsuit and so they're
saying here that there was this graduate
students research that was used and it's
this new way to deliver medication
through the eyes using nanotechnology so
it's like I drop and then you feel bad
something like oh dude that shit's green
it just means I just think about Metal
Gear Solid you know that oh yeah
with the [ __ ] robots and [ __ ] like
yeah a little I just think back there
remember that black mere memory eyedrops
oh yeah I do remember that I should take
the eyedrops so then she could go back
and [ __ ] and in relive certain things
was it do eyedrops I thought it was a
dress I remember that part but I
remember that I remember the memories
one yeah the more they were wine maybe
it was another sci-fi thing that I
watched every beautiful evening three
shows together yeah yeah well yeah so
that's crazy but the same professor has
previously been accused of using his
students as servants
Oh as what this guy's a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] what's the content serving now are
they bringing in [ __ ] food over on
like a big napkin thing and then they
open it up and they do that same thing
your dinner is served
cuz like my brother works for works for
me when four months earlier my podcast
is he my servant because he is that what
you make it out on the check what you I
want that believe me I want all of that
I wanted to dress like a butler [ __ ] you
should you should increase that you how
much part of put that in the work
requirements going in we're gonna have
an employee review and it's going on my
mom made a good servant
she's gone now
right not around Shabbat yeah sure wait
he said she's gone no cuz I'm sad cuz
like the serpent stalking me water well
you have a new servant now she don't
bring me water I have to serve her
that's for sure the tables of turn she
says my laundry yes so this professor
would use foreign students that he had
in his lab Oh cuz they don't know the
rights huh yeah so most of these
students or Indian descent so this
professor he's like these Indian and
Chinese people are awesome they do every
what he's Indian to it so his name is
Amy trees last name is mean tree like
nice tree dish me trust me tree the
Petrie neat truck ashin Mitra is his
name [ __ ] that guy yeah so here's this
face
does he look oh that looks like a guy he
looks like an oil baron just like make
up all that money yes it looks like
Carlos Slim I think he's missing some
gold chains and gold bracelets you'd
imagine if you took the faculty picture
and [ __ ] like iced yeah so he's
what's [ __ ] oh that's his teeth but
you can also tell me that a user grocery
store manager and I believe yeah exactly
come over he's the one he's the one
that's in front of the cash register
that always has the apron on for some
reason yeah right yeah like wait aren't
you supposed to be in the back then if
your neighbor aren't the aprons optional
yeah
but he always has it why do you do that
he has a suit under the like a dress
shirt and tie yeah yeah with this
favorite pen yeah oh I just picture
butcher now oh no you're not only not
with us alright I'm the [ __ ] trained at
all they accuse him of using his
students as like modern slavery because
he would pretty much not directly say it
but pretty much intimidate these
students to say like hey if you don't do
these tours for me I don't know what's
gonna happen to your student visa kind
of thing Oh
what kind of chores so like washing it
or watched watching his dog or washing
his car or like this one little chores
his his basement got flooded and he made
all these students come over and they
spent hours like bucketing [ __ ] out you
know yeah this guy's a legend he's like
didn't you watch Karate Kid these are my
apprentice yeah you learn apparently the
university new about it and they didn't
do anything because he's the this
professor is one of the top dogs and
bringing in fun
they are Kelly dumb they are Kelly Tom
do another sewing yeah cuz he makes so
much money
they're like thank you thank you Petrie
name is Pete when I think of our killing
someone I think of something different
than you yes yeah yeah
I gotta get on near well cuz it's next
because it's what he's current about his
brand has been sullied by spam yes I
think now are killing is wolde are
telling is like you know keeping the
king happy because he's bringing in a
lot of dough and then one way yeah and
let them keep it's like slaves maybe he
peed on one of his slaves
cuz that's old news oh yeah so yeah so
then um they're saying that for like
decades cuz this ball has been in the
sea I hate him so much
it's the cause now that he's skipping
out on the money and doing it on his own
that's when you come after him but
before when he was bringing money for
your school it's all good huh good these
these initial I still like the school
though that's why I went to karate camp
you shout out to this school Ronnie camp
shut up to University of let's go I
would just say I've been sitting here
might you see I just heard myself cuz
I'm like I hate this fool I hate his
wife I hate that school I'm like oh [ __ ]
I think I hate this whole thing you got
a lot of hate in your heart I just want
to shout out all Sara's real quick all
Sara's you have been Sara literally your
bagels are me so I think the only person
I'm really mad at is the teacher because
I'm pretty sure like when you get into
like a graduate school program and like
the matriculation papers or whatever
they're probably it probably states if
you have
findings and then if it gets published
in a certain way the school is going to
take this percentage or head professor
is going to take this percentage this is
how much they're going to take so even
though it seems like straight-up rape
where there take the stood only gets 33%
the students at least know that's what
they're getting themselves into but the
professor just straight stealing his
intellectual property and trying to run
with that whole thing that's for sure is
denying the allegations he's saying that
they had already signed the patent
before the student even jumped on board
in this project so it sounds kind of
shady though because it sounds like he's
working with this other company on the
side was like well he says he has like
his private side thing going the
professor does the professor alright
Mark Zuckerberg we see you so they say
about like hidden like Swiss bank
account [ __ ] I know right I love hearing
angry Indian guys are doing English yeah
Dave I was here I know right I already
got something undecided or whatever and
whatever he says please have some
decency but yeah they're saying the
whole about the whole student thing with
the slavery thing they're saying that in
India it would be something that
students would do for the professor's I
can see it's a pretty caught their toes
over there right so then like in India
they're the type they have the the
culture it's like oh the professor walks
into the room you stand up for them like
that's how crazy they respect them and
to end up in an advantage of that he
totally took advantage of that and so he
abuses power here in America cuz
obviously you can't do that you gotta
try the thing is this guy's my dude I'm
with this guy now
no cuz here's the thing he is a good
bullshitter
like he's like nah man India's like this
so like were you guys talking about like
I love that [ __ ] talk this guy like so
people saying that the with that it's
that way in India it's the former
students that are there saying that they
did he did this to them but these
students they already graduated like
years and years ago but they're just
saying like it's not it's [ __ ] up you
shouldn't be getting away with this so
then now recently when the university
looked into it they hit up all his
students like
and pass and no students would come
forward to say that gang because they're
afraid they're afraid or production
their perception is like you're supposed
to do it this is what we're supposed to
do it wasn't forced so he's not doing it
to non-indian students no that makes
sense because Japanese culture has
apprenticeship culture like if you work
at a sushi restaurant or whatever you're
you're pretty much signing up for not
only the job but a personal assistant
sure so but then I think everyone knows
that they don't do that here it's still
for those [ __ ] up though cuz he's only
doing it to certain students here so he
knows that something's yeah he knows you
can get away with it with your son
students also who will be shipped back
home if he doesn't do it a human
trafficking I want so he I wonder if he
goes around goes do you know anything
about India no you don't know what do
you do in here I come in the room and
someone's like stand up and go around
the room interview it's like I was
transported to the classroom if you go
into like a like a Japanese structure
world right like so for example like for
my karate club like we have to do all
the chores the the lowest level guys
kind of [ __ ] wipe the floors it's
like kind of servant [ __ ] yeah it's but
it's like I'm there to learn karate not
to do this stuff but that's a part of
the culture everyone does it though
doesn't matter they don't make just a
Japanese students do it they make
everybody yeah and then we do other
community service things like trim the
hedges of the church that we get to use
and all that stuff and it's like I
didn't sign up for this but it's a part
of the whole thing is like giving thanks
to the facility that's letting us use it
and things like that and it's all
explained in this case it just sounds
like straight-up
abuse - my whole thing is like so Nicky
was just on vacation in New Zealand with
her mom for a wedding room and at the
end of the trip they they all said like
hey we have to clean up after ourselves
because this
an Airbnb and we didn't pay for the maid
service and Nikki's like what the [ __ ]
why aren't we paying for the maid
service
Nikki's like I'm on [ __ ] vacation I'm
not cleaning [ __ ] she's like I will pay
for this [ __ ] I know like no no no we
don't want to split it or whatever so
Nikki's like well I'm not [ __ ]
cleaning and I support that I would pay
for the maid service Yeah right I would
come on vacation if I'm on vacation I'm
on vacation dude I wanted to see if it
wasn't told beforehand exactly it was
just like what most people the whole
maid service then she's yeah just
everybody so I'm all about respecting
the environment of the place like
including with money if I have to like
if I have to pay for someone else to
respect it pitching in some way to show
thanks or whatever but I don't want to
[ __ ] clean any yeah that's all I'm
trying to say thank you
[Music]
[Music]